wait is he in you right oh yeah oh no
he's he's right there I thought this
would feel a lot more uncomfortable
watching you and sitting next to you and
it doesn't right he's that weird my name
is Jane Jupiter I'm 29 I'm Jenna I'm 32
and I'm a virgin I am a virgin but
that's kind of a myth so I'm in the
adult industry and have been for about
nine years been a virgin my whole life
hi sweetie I'm Jenna I'm Jane so nervous
it'll be fine thank you yeah
all right so my first question for you
is did you ever come close to losing
your virginity yes I almost had sex with
a guy this summer but he didn't have a
condom which was like thank God because
later on I was like you know I didn't
want to have sex with them really yeah I
just kind of going with the flow
yeah and I was like drunk and so yeah so
I was like and I knew him like I trusted
him yeah like maybe you know whatever
and then he didn't have it and I was
like yeah thank God so you're like
you're not like actively trying to lose
your virginity right now then you're
probably kind of keeping the brakes on
it a little bit well I don't really date
or put myself out there so the answer is
yeah like I'm not I guess if I really
wanted to I'd be like hitting the
pavement every day I try it it would not
be hard get out there very gorgeous okay
yeah I'm very nervous when did you lose
your virginity
I was actually 14 and yeah I had been
kind of fooling around like before that
but it was 14 when I like decided
actively that I wanted to have sex so I
had been dating someone for like four
months and we both like kind of came
from you know like conservative
Christian like upbringing so so then we
yeah we decided to have sex I will say
though if
someone had taught me about the clitoris
I would not have had that but yeah why
meaning like cuz it's like on the
outside sure is where it actually feels
great comprehensive sex ed with like
even a little talk about masturbation
and there that could actually keep
people with their majorities for like a
lot longer in my opinion right how
important is your virginity to you it
used to be a lot more important in both
the negative and positive way so it used
to be positive and important when I was
like waiting for the right guy and
saving myself for marriage which is
special flour and then it became
important in a negative way because I
would use my virginity with each passing
year to like [ __ ] on myself and be like
well now you're a 26 year old virgin now
you're 27 now you're [ __ ] loser and
it's like within the past couple years
I've just gotten over it
I think turning 30 helps and it's not
important and yeah who the foot of hairs
how important was it for you I mean yeah
so it was really important in the
beginning which is why I did try to wait
a little little bit I tried and you know
I remember I got a lecture from like
someone that came to my school he would
go to the different schools and you know
talk to them and he wasn't allowed to
like preach but he was a preacher he was
a preacher he said something along the
lines of you know your rigidity is like
a stick of gum and once you have sex
you're like a chewed up piece of gum and
you can't just put that cheat a piece of
gum back in the wrapper and fold it and
say that it's the same because it's not
girls and boys are just the girls girls
well was everyone but you know that he's
mostly talking about girls cuz that's
how it is oh my god that's awful
is there anything about sex that scares
you yes
yeah um that's mostly why I've been like
putting it off but as I start to talk
about it more I'm like I think what
scares me is intimacy which intimacy
doesn't mean sex like yeah hopefully we
all know that but strictly sex stuff
that scares me is getting pregnant
getting an STD and then like someone
seeing me naked which
like well that's scary but yeah but I'm
also like well I mean hopefully they'll
be into it I don't yeah how do you feel
about people seeing you naked
I don't mind at all people seeing me
naked it's it's fun I think you know I
wasn't always like that and I was less
experienced I have like horrible anxiety
about it but now you know I I'm open to
it I like it
I'm more comfortable naked I'd be more
comfortable filming this naked honestly
really yeah I just feel like I'm like in
my element and I like I can like hold my
own a lot more so do you put a label on
your sexuality
I used to it used to be like I'm
straight and I'm a virgin and this is
that and I'm sexually repressed and here
we go I got it and now I am well I'm
still sexually repressed I'm getting a
little bit better at that I'm trying to
do more things over the past couple
years have kind of realized that I'm bi
and so that's been interesting I was
about like 13 like going through puberty
when I realized that I was bisexual okay
and I would have dreams you know about
like really hot stuff and then I'd wake
up and I would just think that this is
the devil trying to tempt me away from
Lord Jesus and Christianity and and it
was actually like really hard for me to
like come to terms with that were you
able to talk to anyone at that age about
that no no not at Kansas and not country
and odds no way yeah yep so are you
saving yourself for marriage no no no
yeah I don't know I was yeah I think I
was until I got to college and then I
was like well I was told unfortunately
by a lot of people people really close
to me too that a guy isn't gonna wait
yeah so I stopped waiting for marriage I
was still waiting for like the perfect
guy right which then that expired and so
it went into something else so yeah but
now not waiting for marriage I don't
know if I will get married my next
question for you is do you watch
pornography I do yeah you do yes I do
watch
I watched porn have you ever seen any
porn of mine no no is this all you on
here must listen it yes we go to fold
you alright yeah I love it this is great
with women's and make it out that's so
nice
sorry okay have you ever taken any nude
pictures or videos of yourself I'm very
interested in this okay so here's the
thing I wouldn't send them to anyone but
I did a couple times would take what to
try to take a selfie and be like what
would it's fine
what would it look like if someone were
on top of me having sex like what would
it cuz I am like me and a bra great me
with my bra off there's I'm a promise
and laying down like yeah the worst
and so I've deleted those um they might
be in some [ __ ] cloud which i think
is re a bi but I really hope not but
they probably are you know whatever it
was years ago so do your parents know
what you do yeah they do know what I do
I've been surprisingly supportive about
oh that's really good yeah it's really
awesome I was I was pretty worried about
it but when they found out they were
just like yeah like as long as you know
you're being safe and you're happy so
did you tell them or did they find out
they kind of found out okay yeah does
working in the adult film industry
affect your relationships no it doesn't
affect them I would say I've been in an
open relationships and it's like for a
long time so that doesn't really affect
them and then everyone else that I'm
like seeing casually you know I usually
will tell them right away and I tend to
like go in and crowd that's pretty like
sex positive and feminist do you think
virginity has been fetishized
yeah I do think it has my fetish size in
like a sexy way you know but also like a
more religious way it's over-the-top you
know to think all the time that
virginity is like something so important
that either must be preserved or
you know must be like giving away so
I've never seen it in like a positive
way yeah cuz I've always had kind of
negative reactions of people being like
no one's gonna wait for you no one wants
to sleep with a virgin right the
fetishizing part of it that I've seen is
like you're like for sale or you're on
this pedestal and you're like perfect
and it means purity and you're like it
doesn't mean any of those things those
are all you know it's like a myth the
language around it sucks like it being
taken it being given away it's like lost
yeah it's just crap I don't want to be
anyone's fetish that's a big fear of
mine because part of me thinks like if
virginity is your fetish then at a
certain point you're gonna be done with
me I said before you walked in they
asked me what my biggest fear was and I
was like that she's gonna think I'm not
cool and that's she won't like me but
you know like wrongfully but I expected
you to come in and be like very dominant
and very just like maybe that's what I
was done wishing I don't I don't know
but I just thought it was going to be
sort of like that I you were gonna talk
at me and like right you know be more
domineering and what do I think now I
think you're lovely
I'm very comfortable yeah I feel like
that's that's also how I feel like I
wasn't worried that you would be like
judgmental because I assumed that you
wouldn't be doing this actually if you
weren't pretty open-minded but I did not
expect you to have like so many fun
experiences even alone you know that I
can really relate to you alright we're
gonna go make out
[Music]
you